Hello everybody and welcome back to the
channel. Today we've got yet another
systems design 3.0 video. Uh this one is
going to be about the Facebook like
button. Now I personally have sent a lot
of likes on both Facebook posts and
stories in the past. Tend to also send
some fire emojis with them. Uh and maybe
surprisingly I rarely get responded to.
I don't know why that is. But uh yeah,
let's go ahead and get into this one cuz
I'm in a bit of a rush. Let's set up
some context for this problem here.
Facebook posts are visible both on the
Facebook site as well as external
websites. When viewing a post, a user
can attach a like to it. If they've
liked the post, they can dislike it.
When the post comes up, there should
also be an attached count of the total
number of likes on the post itself. If
you think about it, it's really
important that when a user likes a post
and then perhaps refreshes the page that
they see their like reflected. The same
applies for unliking a post that they
had previously liked. On the contrary,
something like the count of likes for a
given post can be a little bit stale.
We'll see why a trade-off like this is
helpful in a bit. In a problem like
this, we need to support four main API
endpoints. The first is for a user to
see whether or not they've liked a post.
The second is for a user to like a post.
Next, a user can attempt to unlike a
post. And then finally, we need to be
able to get the count of likes per post.
By implementing these endpoints, we'll
satisfy our functional requirements.
Thanks to the help of Chat GBT, let me
quote some pretty accurate capacity
estimates here. Per day, Facebook
receives around 5 billion likes across
all posts. While their most popular post
ever amassed 4 million likes in a day,
I'll instead use Instagram's most
popular post, which got over 50 million
likes in 24 hours. Believe it or not,
it's not a video of me twerking. What a
surprise. Breaking these numbers down to
a per second rate. This means that we
have to handle 60,000 likes per second
with a maximum possible throughput of
600 likes per second on an individual
post. The latter rate is important when
determining whether we'll ever encounter
a celebrity issue due to the number of
clicks on a given post. The first thing
that we'll cover is answering the
question of whether a user has liked a
given post. Because our application
servers are once again stateless, we can
scale them out as we please and
roundroin requests to them via multiple
active load balancers. Note the right
side of the diagram where we have a
likes database. The schema here is very
simple. It's just a mapping between user
ID and post ID where a row in the table
indicates that the user has liked a
post. This is a MySQL table that can be
scaled with Vitess using the hash of the
user ID. We'll be using single leader
asynchronous replication for it. To
check if a user has liked a post in the
past, we make a request to our servers
and simply check if a row for that post
ID and user ID exists in our likes
database. When liking or disliking a
post, our servers first write or remove
the like to or from the likes table.
From there, we use to perform change
data capture, syncing the data change to
Kafka. Finally, we have a Kafka consumer
group pulling these changes and applying
them to our next database table, which
tracks the like counts of each post.
This table is called post likes count,
and it lives in a distributed MongoDB
cluster, which is partitioned based on
the post ID. We also use a hash index
per node in order to keep reads and
writes to the table very fast. To get
the number of likes for a given post, we
first check if the result is cached in
our look aside reddis cluster which is
partitioned by post ID. If not, we'll
fetch the result from the post likes
count MongoDB instead. Now that we've
gone through our highle design, let's
break down our decision-m process. Keep
in mind that one of the requirements of
this problem is that when a user likes a
post and receives an acknowledgement
from our backend, the like is instantly
reflected. Sometimes this is called read
after write consistency. In our case, we
can achieve this by devoting a simple
database table to all of the likes. As
long as we are always making reads from
an up-to-date copy of the data, we'll
see our like reflected. The schema for
this table should be very simple. At its
core, we really only need to reflect two
fields for a like, the user ID and the
post ID. In reality, there's probably a
lot more metadata attached here for data
analysis purposes. Even though our
necessary fields can be reflected with
two longs, which is equal to 16 bytes,
let's conservatively estimate that each
write will be around 100 bytes in total.
To check whether a user has liked a
post, we'll simply check whether a row
exists for the given user ID and post ID
combination. To like a post, we'll
create that row if it doesn't exist. To
delete a like, we'll remove that row if
it exists. Note that because we're
sending in a pretty constant stream of
individual likes to our table, we
probably want to be using an OOLTP
database here. Let's now go through how
we'd get the number of likes for a given
post. From our likes table, we can run a
query to count all rows with a given
post ID. In reality, this can get
expensive. Most transactional databases
aren't premputing the counts of rows
with a certain key value, unlike some
analytical ones. If we have to do a
linear row scan to figure out our
counts, popular posts may require
scanning many gigabytes of data at once,
which would take a few seconds even with
really good SSDs, we could maybe use a
typical Reddis cache here, so we only
have to perform this computation once.
That being said, unless we configure a
really short TTL, our like counts for
these posts may become stale very
quickly. And if we're frequently purging
the cache number of likes per popular
posts, that just means more slow user
queries from the database. We don't want
that. Instead, it may really benefit us
to premp compute the count of likes for
all posts. While this may have less of a
performance benefit for posts with a few
likes, it can make a noticeable
difference for all of these celebrity
posts. Let's consider what we should do
about table partitioning. These are
fairly big tables. At 5 billion likes a
day, each one being 100 bytes, we're
writing 166 terabytes of data every
single year and around a pabyte over 6
years. Additionally, we're handling
60,000 writes per second. Forgetting
about the rights for a moment, users
must fetch whether they've liked a post
and the post's like count every single
time that they view it. If this occurs
10 times as much as the number of likes,
which come in at a rate of 60,000 per
second, that's 600,000 reads per second.
If we use this 10:1 ratio to apply to
popular posts, this means that we could
have some moments where hot posts are
viewed by 6,000 people a second,
potentially hammering the shard those
live on. Even if someone wanted to argue
that we'd benefit from partitioning by
post ID for computing like counts, we've
already decided that we're going to
fetch those from a different view. For
this reason, we may prefer to use the
hash of the user ID in order to
determine which partition a row should
live on. Unlike roundroining, this
allows us to easily figure out which
shard to read from when determining
whether a user has liked a post. It also
comes with the added benefit of being
able to see all of the post IDs that a
user has liked. Since no user can
physically like that many posts, we
should get fairly balanced load across
our shards here. Okay, admittedly I like
a lot of posts, but that's because I'm
pretty good at gooning. It therefore
seems beneficial to create an index on
user ID and then post ID. This further
speeds up queries to determine whether a
user has liked a given post. We'll now
introduce a second table, post like
counts, which is responsible for keeping
track of the number of likes on each
post. It is a very simple schema, post
ID and count, which represents the
number of likes on that post. One naive
way to update this table would be to do
so right when a user likes a post. For
starters, this would mean that we'd have
hundreds of updates to the count on the
same popular post. Since this is a
counter, we'd need to use atomic
operations to ensure that we don't lose
any updates from concurrent writes.
Worse yet, we're also prone to bad
partial failure scenarios. The right to
the likes table could go through, but
the right to the postl like counts table
could fail, resulting in the two tables
being in an inconsistent state. While we
don't need the count of likes to be
immediately accurate when a user reads
it, we do need our two tables to be
eventually consistent with one another.
Recall that we need read after write
consistency for our like data. That
means the first place that the like
needs to go is into a database. If we
put it in Kafka, for example, we'd have
no guarantee on when the like would be
reflected back to the user. Then a user
could like a post, receive an
acknowledgement from our backend,
refresh the page, and it could seem like
their action was lost. Recall that if we
try to write to two systems at once,
we're prone to partial failure
scenarios. For this reason, we want the
likes table to be our source of truth.
Once a right is in the database, we need
it propagated to our post-like counts
table. We can accomplish this with
something known as change data capture.
CDC, as it's called for short, hooks
into the replication log of a database
and syncs it to Kafka. One tool that
allows you to do this with a wide
variety of databases is called Dubzium.
Personally, I'm not a big fan of sifting
through other people's logs, but to each
their own. Since the replication log is
itself durable and messages in Kafka are
durable when configured properly, we
know that even if database failures are
present, we should expect to eventually
see them in Kafka. From there, we can
have a Kafka consumer that takes in
those messages and syncs them to the
post likes count table. In our likes
table, we need readyour consistency.
This probably means that we want to
avoid using something like multiler
replication. This is because a user
could send a like to one of our database
leaders and then read from another and
not see their like reflected. In theory,
we've actually got a couple of options
here. We could use leaderless
replication. If we use quorum
consistency, we can guarantee that the
set of database nodes that we write to
and read from will always overlap. This
means that we'll have an up-to-date
value for each key on at least one of
the nodes that we read from and can use
client assigned write timestamps to
determine which one is the most recent.
The other is to use single leader
replication. As long as we always read
from our single leader, we'll be sure to
see any likes that we've made. Note that
assuming this replication is
asynchronous, we can lose some data due
to failovers as it may not have reached
the replica before our leader fails.
Recall that we're going to use Debzium
to sync the data from the likes table to
a change data stream. If we were to use
Cassandra and go with leaderless
replication, it becomes a little bit
more complex. CDC on Cassandra requires
reading from many different replicas
because the working set of data for one
partition can potentially live across
many different nodes. While this could
work, let's just keep things simple and
stick to a typical SQL database for our
likes table. We can sync the change data
from a node in each shard into Kafka.
Because we'll be creating tens of
thousands of likes per second, we
probably want to have multiple
partitions of our change data Kafka
topic. Recall that our likes table is
partitioned on user ID. That being said,
if we have our change data topic
partitioned by user ID, multiple
consumers will be writing data for the
same post in our sync table and we'll
therefore be experiencing lock
contention with one another, especially
for popular posts. Instead, it would be
ideal if all likes for a given post were
handled by the same Kafka consumer. The
default behavior of Debeesium is to use
a primary key of the database in order
to route information to a Kafka
partition. However, we can override this
using a single message transform or SMT
for short. In our case, we'll use the
hash of the post ID modulo the number of
Kafka partitions. Because even the most
popular posts are only receiving a few
hundred likes per second, a few
partitions of a Kafka topic can still
easily keep up with this right load. We
don't need to worry about the celebrity
problem here. In our derived view, we
need to ensure that each click is
processed exactly once in terms of
ensuring that each click is handled at
least once. Recall that messages in
Kafka are durable. We'll use multiple
Kafka consumers in a consumer group to
ensure that all messages are handled
even if one of the consumer nodes fails.
Let's also go over how we can ensure
that each message is processed at most
once. The technique for doing so is very
reminiscent of our prior video about
adclick aggregation. Simply put, we
should store a Kafka partition and
offset number alongside each row so that
we'll only incorporate updates to the
table that we haven't yet seen. Each
incoming like is treated as a plus one
and each deletion of a like is treated
as a minus one. If we want, we can even
batch those updates in our consumer to
minimize database rights and achieve
better write throughput for popular
posts. We just need to first check the
post like count table to see the last
processed Kafka offset for a given post,
which tells us which events from our
change data stream to include and which
to drop. At the end of the day, we still
need fast reads. Posts are likely viewed
in order of magnitude more than they are
liked, and we'll need to load a post's
like counts for all of those views. For
this reason, we can use a very simple
look aside cache. Our application
servers will first check the cache for
the data. In the event of a cache miss,
it'll fetch the true result from the
database and place it in our Reddus
cache. Reddus can handle hundreds of
thousands of simple reads per second,
meaning that we really have no need to
be concerned about hot shards here. We
can keep our TTLS in the span of minutes
to ensure that our data doesn't get too
stale and use an LRU eviction policy
since we don't know which posts will be
popular in advance. Much of the
interesting part of this video, in my
opinion, is learning why we should be
using change data capture as a way of
maintaining derived data views. We can
use the besium to get all changes in a
persistent store so that in theory our
derived view should be eventually
consistent with our main view. First,
we'll discuss whether that's actually
the case. Next, we'll discuss whether
there's any way to avoid change data
capture in the first place. Imagine a
situation where we have DESium reading
from the replication log of a primary
database where the database is doing
asynchronous replication to a follower.
We have a race condition here. Dubesium
can send a right from the replication
log to Kafka before any follower node
applies it and then the leader can go
down. The right will then be lost when a
replica takes over as the primary
database but it will be reflected in our
derived view because it is in Kafka. Now
our views will never be totally
consistent with one another. There are
two fairly easy ways to ensure that our
derived view is always consistent with
the primary table. The first is to use a
strongly consistent database. That way
rights can never be lost. Many OLTP
databases these days use consensus
algorithms to create a distributed log
of rights, allowing them to be strongly
consistent while also still tolerating
some node failures. Some of these
include Google Spanner and Cockroach DB.
In theory, this may lower our right
throughput into the likes table, but
these databases can be scaled out
horizontally enough that it shouldn't
matter too much. Another option would be
to actually create our database replicas
from the change data capture Kafka
topic. That way we'd ensure that Kafka
is the source of truth for a replication
log and any replica that becomes the
primary after a leader failure would
have seen the same messages as any
derived views. I'm not aware of any
databases that use CDC as the
replication mechanism. So we'd have to
rebuild the failover logic ourselves
which would make life a lot more
complex. Let's think if we have any
other options that avoid a bunch of
custom code and don't require consensus
algorithms in the critical path. Recall
that we want to ensure that every write
that has been sent to the CDC topic has
been successfully replicated. A pretty
easy way to do this would just be to run
Dezium on a replica. This isn't
supported by every database that has a
Debzium connector, but one that does
work, for example, is my SQL. Again,
there are some subtleties here. Imagine
that we're running DBZM on a replica,
but then on a failover, a less
up-to-date replica is chosen to be the
new leader, and some of the rights on
our DESM replica are now lost. We can
avoid this by ensuring that we always
choose the most up-to-date replica
during a leader failover. There are many
MySQL replication tools that can do
this. For example, Orchestrator. Note
that when we do so, if the new leader
was the replica running the Dezium
connector, we'd now need to point
Debeesium to a different replica.
Fortunately, Orchestrator can actually
hit a web hook upon a failover to alert
us that this has happened. If it does,
we can run some custom logic where we
ask orchestrator for the addresses of
the followers and configure our Dubesium
connector to point to one of those.
Dubesium has logic to resume from its
last committed replication log offset.
So we should be good to go. Is it really
worth it to do this? Honestly, probably
not. Again, there's a lot of custom code
here, and it's definitely possible that
I missed some race conditions. For
example, the primary node could send
data to our DSian replica, have it
persisted to Kafka, and then both of
them could go down. Now, the data would
be lost, but still reflected in our
derived view. Recall that all of our
APIs can be implemented pretty easily if
we just have a single primary data store
that is partitioned based on the post
ID. The main issue that we run into is
that counting rows with a given ID
requires a scan of the table. And many
users will be doing this to fetch the
like counts for popular posts to the
tune of 6,000 operations per second. For
these popular posts, we may be able to
actually pretty easily solve things with
Reddus. Let's model our data as post ID
as the reddest key and a set of user ids
as the reddest value. Since Reddus is
just using a normal hash set, computing
the cardality of it is O of one. The
actual amount of data stored for a given
post, even super popular ones, is just
in the few gigabyte range. Certainly
enough to keep in memory. Individual
nodes can handle hundreds of thousands
of simple operations per second. So we
don't really need to worry about things
from a throughput perspective.
If we're concerned that there are too
many Reddus nodes and things get
expensive, we could always store just
the posts of verified users on Reddus
and if otherwise store them in a normal
transactional database. Well guys, I
hope that you enjoyed this video. As you
can see, uh we're starting to kind of
build upon the concepts uh from episode
to episode. Did a lot of you know
exactly once processing in the prior
episode and also kind of dancing around
the line of CDC. So, I think in this
video it's a good one to talk about kind
of change data capture in general and
the nuances of it. The reason I'm doing
so is because in the next video we're
probably going to do uh like a newsfeed
systems design and I don't want to spend
you know 20 plus minutes talking about
you know uh building both a following
and followers table uh which need to use
change data capture to keep one another
in sync. Uh so yeah, hopefully this is
useful. I will see you all in the next
one and I'm looking forward to